The general good experience,
it's very interesting whether this
Harvey Weinstein case is going to go.
It's very interesting where it's going
to go right now he has Benjamin Braf is
a charity and if you see what happened,
Benjamin Bratt push for dismissal and he
didn't get it that the lawyer said the
judge said a trial date to get a trial
date.
Harvey Weinstein is going to go through
them,
more money to pay off,
time to go for time.
Then he's going to fire Benjamin,
Braf and show up with two women,
primarily one black and one Asian or one
white and one Asian,
and this is when this trouser,
and again,
very interesting,
our results over the higher millions of
dollars and prosecute in a private
investigators.
They'll interview boyfriends.
They're going to interview this case.
It would be very interesting,
unlike the cosby case,
weight caused me.
Didn't really fuck.
How do you know he's going to do all
this stuff because I know this is what I
would do.
I know you come to me and you go,
I'm getting busted for this.
What do I do?
Because of how I grew up around those
people,
this is what you do,
Benjamin.
Braf cannot ask a woman the same
question a woman could ask a woman,
so I'm going to go there with either a
black woman,
an Asian woman,
or a white woman.
My first two choices are a black woman.
You want to get the diversity angle to
get the diversity angle and I want to
get that.
You can't.
You're saying that because you're a
black woman.
Chinese woman.
What?
I'm trying to stare at me.
Did you ever really watched the people
versus Oj Simpson?
No,
I didn't.
Very interesting and it said it's time
that you sat.
No,
the holidays.
Yeah,
the fx version.
I watched one episode that seemed very
good.
Very interesting.
How he pulled a dream team together.
It's going to cost you 10 mil.
Listen to me.
Gee,
you got two options.
You can go into like cars being paid two
mil and make believe you're blind or
we've put together a fuck it.
Then you see him.
He went to live with that milky shit
over his eyes,
like the guy from Kung Fu.
Let me,
when we were kids foods father followed
was like half blind and shit.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Magnesia and shit.
That's how will in that plan.
Like I'm sick.
Routine.
He's got cataracts.
Cool.
Cosby.
Yeah,
but he didn't have cataracts.
When was that?
When he put the pill in the water,
he didn't know.
He knows what.
He knows what the fuck.
So he's taking three steps.
Read your fucking,
you know.
Yeah,
he knows,
but hobby has to play this hand.
This is what America is about to watch.
They're going to watch something fucking
crazy.
He knows he go in their bedroom and
Braf.
Benjamin Bratt had gravano look at the
list of Benjamin.
Preface and Benjamin Braf can attack a
woman show.
You look at like legal cases like
supports
on paper is to John Jones versus
Gustafson.
I went to New York last week and I went
to the Metropolitan Museum of art with
my daughter.
She loves art and while I was sitting
there I was added saying,
go on your own.
Because my daughter didn't want me
taking pictures in front of the
statutes.
Anyway.
She was like,
Daddy,
get out of the pictures of the stash,
so I'm like,
what the fuck am I hanging out with you
for?
She was in the Chinese way.
I wanted to see the Armenian when,
but it was funny.
I was thinking about when I was 21 and
22 Joe Rogan,
I would get stoned to the gills and go
to the Museum of natural history.
The museum or my hobbies back then since
I was such a loan and then people
looking for me,
I was always a criminal.
I would go over the bridge to either go
to one of those museums.
Why would sit in the courtroom?
I would go to a place that had a fucking
Italian sandwich and I get a bag of wise
potato chips in a 16 ounce coke and you
go to any court room.
Court starts at seven at the
metropolitan downtown.
I take the a train and I'd walk.
I forget now what you know.
This is 1983 81.
I was a kid and I would sit.
None observed hort.
I learned how to.
Plus I grew up in that.
You were what you would sit and watch
night court,
like you'd watch a basketball game,
like a game with a sandwich and a soda
and potato chips.
Men,
Chicago this year I think there was a
paper view.
You were there,
right?
Yes.
So something happened and I was late
getting to the arena and they had cut
off kind of the loading dock.
I couldn't get to it.
So I had my oldest daughter with me and
so we're having a walk through where all
the crowds walking in and you know,
dudes all the golden snitch and get a
picture golden snitch.
My daughter's like,
what the fuck's going on?
How old is your daughter?
So she's 22,
so two days ago,
Christmas morning I'm opening up
presence.
So I get the presence for my daughters,
the three of them and my middle daughter
is very artistic and so they create
these cool sculpted beer mugs and
there's four of them.
One of them's like Bald Guy Brewing
Novitsky something and one of them says
golden snitch brewing company.
So it's cool looking thing and she,
she drew me a black and white kind of
rendition of all four,
which I'm gonna hang up really cool.
So then my girlfriend's there,
so she hands me the box and she's been
telling me all along.
She goes,
I got you the best fucking present ever
in the history of presence.
Mike.
The hell is this.
So I opened up the box.
Oh my.
She's got this series of t shirts I
think.
What size are you?
Large.
There we go,
man.
So you,
since you created it,
you literally and figuratively have to
wear it.
Now
this is outrageous.
So that picture there,
there's some
go baby ladies.
Gentlemen,
circle is closed.
So I posted a boot on this or something
that's pretty bad.
King from the new series.
Moscow,
I think I can say this.
Hopefully they'll let me back in,
but it's out in front of KGB.
FSB,
you headquarters through that building
in the background is KGB.
F has now known as FSB.
Oh Wow.
So yeah.
So I posted a picture of.
She got me like 20 shirts.
I put them on private instagram,
facebook,
everybody in the world like take my
money,
man.
Where can I get one last ends tomorrow?
Right.